far there are six omicron variant cases
of coronavirus here in nevada state
health officials are stepping up efforts
to get more people and particularly more
children vaccinated before christmas
hector mejia live this afternoon near
flamingo and maryland parkway hector you
spoke with governor steve sissellac
about the severity of this new variant
this is where we had that conversation
with the governor and he said while the
omicron variant is spreading rapidly so
far it hasn't been as severe as other
variants and he reiterated vaccines and
boosters are still the best way to fight
it as we head into holiday gatherings
the hospitalizations are much much lower
when you've been vaccinated and the
deaths are really reduced so that's what
this is about we cannot overwhelm our
health care system again like we did
before governor steve sislike encourages
vaccinating against the coronavirus as
omicron creeps across the u.s we've come
a long way with our economy we don't
want to take a step back we don't want
to go backwards and have any more
restrictions put in place newly
appointed lieutenant governor lisa cano
burkhead joined sissylac at horizon
ridge wellness clinic where they offered
vaccines and christmas toys to children
including the groom's family i got laid
off in the pandemic and didn't have to
wait
several months before i got back into
employment angelina groom says it's been
rough being a single mother with four
young boys earlier this year we got our
cars stolen so a lot of their
hoverboards bikes and everything that we
went to the park with were in the
vehicle ferdinand griffin also knows
what it's like to barely make ends meet
he picked up toys to put under the tree
for his two grandchildren sometimes we
don't have the funds to
to get what they really want
and at this event earlier this morning
the governor also talked about the death
toll in nevada saying the coronavirus
claimed the lives of over 8 300 people
across the state reporting near flamingo
and maryland parkway hector mejia live
local now